this is I do not agree with this all
this is nonsense like I do not agree
with this at all so this whatever this
is I'm not signing off to you can put me
in the video that's why they got us to
sign off before the video
started is that what we sign yeah I I
agree with this your face is by this 11
come the thumbnail this is
[Music]
bull dancing the chura Flav and his
partner Turkish it's got to make you
saying you good good James you know
actually going to see see it do you like
my table James James right James how we
feel that you don't know each other yeah
I I've seen him on YouTube he's quite
Deal on YouTube about as far as I know
you've got that great podcast you yeah F
[__] right so we
have so we've got a table here and then
on the table we have a pitch and we're
going to do something pretty spicy which
is try and put together a combined 11
yeah of the current two squs of Arsenal
and Tottenham all right so Shall We
Begin let's let's begin in a hotly
contested area in my opinion the
Midfield area let's start with Arsenal
then you've got so many options there
what would be your three do you want to
get ahead of this well I'm just saying
there's two here for Spurs so you can
have rice if you like do you want to
know Mae party rice and for that comment
old the
God because this one would this one I
don't mind a little debate about cuz I
like Madison a hell of a lot and we're
going to talk about Madison shortly I'm
going to let you let you talk about him
first but the reality is there's no
debate here for me part on form is the
best six out of the lot and there's no
debate here because you need to have
Dean rice in this free and what Dean
rice does parte doesn't what parte does
deam rice doesn't rice has to play there
rice has to play there because there's
too much talent here okay so it okay so
are we are we going to do two at once
let's say I agree on rice here six I
I'll hold my hands up with that so okay
you're giving you're giving one away
rice is better than basuma at the time
of recording then this is what I'm going
to this is what I'm bringing in if rice
goes there older God goes here can I
just before we do how I how would you
how would you debate that then okay so
let me do your job for you right so I I
thought you would have liked what T
should put forward there because I think
there's a world where you could have a
combined 11 and you can have Declan rice
as an eight you can have basuma as a six
and and you can live in a world with
Madison who's is there I think there's
an argument there but you haven't that's
two out of your three I'm not really
bothered about this take it no you know
what I'm I'm backt checking it's rice
for here because I see what James is
trying to do there's no chance of it
happening rice is my option I'm not
trying to do anything I've heard enough
rice is here I think flab agrees and and
James you've already spoke right and
these is where I'm going to blow you
we'll get we get into that so first
one's done honest let go Dean rice makes
it in as the sixth okay where would you
like to go next VB in that Midfield then
uh I'm going to go Ben tenor here oh
benan cor let me tell you benon cor has
had horrendous injuries right but he is
the most underrated midfielder in the
Premier League so much so actually
begins to be not underrated some people
starting to rate him now but before it
was just the Spurs fans this kid is
incredible and if I was building a
combined 11 that would undoubtedly win
the league Bon cor would be in that
Midfield you've lost James yeah is benor
not there no benor is not there benor is
exactly where I said he would be my
problem with that is there's two names
that I can't Overlook for those two
positions and I'm being fair here cuz
one of those is the Tottenham name and
it's not benen Chason Madison 100% and
you can't look past older God I'm going
to throw his name into the into the mix
I understand why you're going to throw
it in obviously I would if if the rols
are revers but man just doesn't just
doesn't appear in big games just doesn't
do it does he that's unfair I think
that's even last season look at the look
at his performance across the season 15
goals matching de Bron's record from
goals from a midfielder in his in his
first real season as Captain as well can
I tell you why stats aren't that
important cuz perisic has 11 assists in
the Premier League last year would he
get anywhere near this team perisic in
on his day is quality
so what's happening here why
you he using perisic as a baret fors you
know stats don't mean nothing but
perisic is a quality player in his day
was know up there with the very best can
we quickly just maybe have let's move
back let's move back to here older guard
has to pick up one of these two
positions I'm sorry I don't know how
James feels but he has to he was the
second best I'll say just behind de BR
because of De br's clutch moments
towards the end but he was the second
best midfielder in the league last if
you could swap odard for Madison would
you swap him no lies and see this is
where I think you know with a combined
11 you got to manage the combined 11 and
this is where I think you made a grave
error stop saying that because I I think
the obvious thing now becomes that it's
it's Madison and and odard if you got a
final an FA Cup Final and you can play
odard or Madison in that final it's more
for you Turkish I think I think you're a
bit more neutral in this one who would
you like to play in that game in that
fin oh God okay poker
face
that's so what was that thing you said
about when I would have got
to what was it let's not look back
I think you could have you could have
lived in a world where you could have
had basuma and Madison no one want to
live in that world though but what
instead of rice that world's gone right
let's move on to the front three let's
go left to
right who would you like on the left
hand side a
challenge it's not not for you isn't
definitely um Paris Paris had 11 assists
in the leag last season if he was fully
fit you got to accept the stats
by your own admission he is a great
player and then if we look at
Martinelli's numbers then yeah we won't
talk about pises um how do I defend this
how do how do I do this this feels like
a short a balance between Defending Your
club and you know your your reputation
still up oh that's in TS that's been in
tis years ago I'm not worried about that
I just thought there's there's no one on
the left I could possibly put in ahead
of Martinelli that's is the issue yeah I
feel like this is very very simple is
Hurricane's really
Ty have definitely had two in cuz son
gets in the head of Martinelli yeah on
the left fair just it's the body of work
you got to look at the body of work and
Kane gets in over any of their number
nines they never number nine so Kane's
got he's stop saying Kane's got his
finished
finished such a why did he do it hey but
look at look at what who you've got
there through the middle now son doing
bits his rightful place yeah so I mean
we I mean there's not the our option
really here um this put Martinelli in
just quickly put we'll put it him in but
just just so in case there any Spurs
fans going why don't you argue about
this because we talking about Manor
Solomon richon yes not not no we're not
talking about at all Brenan Johnson one
for the future not a left Winger right
winger very much okay not a ring or for
the red Chip's been placed anyway yes
absolutely let's let's move on do you
want to go for Center forward or you
want to go over to the right just so I
can get a win yeah yeah if just is there
an argument here because I know humon um
hasn't played his entire career for the
middle but he has done this season and
that's where we're talking so I'd say
I'd say 100% number n plays number nine
for South Korea more ruthless more
lethal if you're wanting to win the
league in this imaginary world this
horrendous imaginary world where we're
sharing
players um if we had to do that you
would want some up up top I don't know
look at how many time Man City won the
league with an and out Striker Liverpool
won the league with for me know getting
what 12 goals modern day football has
brought Wingers being the the bigger
goal scoring threat than than the
strikers now because that is an optional
false now listen I'm not arguing that
sun doesn't deserve that position are
can I also can we just agree that the
most important role of a striker is to
score goals yep okay that is why Harry
Kane is a better
Striker oh my God what he's not you just
agreed the parameter my we agree did we
not just agree the paramet everyone
heard that you said
yes wrong comb you're going to be
getting more DMS soon I'm telling you
this minute now he he is better than on
reader that's just we'll save that for
another one cuz that's an hour in if you
want a debate that yeah there isn't a
debate can I not judge that one that's
fine on the right hand side is this an
easy one with Baya saaka or does Ki have
any way kosi has a conversation but
sackur is no is the answer unfortunately
not for me um and the video CU it would
be interesting if we could debate this
but obviously no one is putting Saka
above kosi but Koski is an excellent
excellent not just forward but
midfielder as well and he will grow into
this past kogu team as a crucial aspect
to our title winning team in
2025 interesting okay and how many goals
and assists does he get in that season
he's going to get 15 goals and 15
assists which doesn't really matter
anyway because some's going to score 45
is it so there you go the internet
doesn't forget FL you know if this pops
up in 2025 then that would look good if
you I think I'll deal with it I'll be a
to be fine okay into the back line here
and let's start off with the center
backs what always winds me up about this
position is cuz Arsenal fans they know
they know about CBA right we all know
about that g good right but they'll go
oh no but what about Gabrielle which is
not the conversation that we need to
have Gabrielle can't be in a
conversation with Romero we cannot why
not well I don't know one w a World Cup
recently yeah but we're talking
Tottenham AR talking Argentina England I
know vanen is better than Gabrielle you
don't you know that I know I I know it
because I I've seen seen no I watched a
lot of wolburg last season you'd be
surprised yeah yeah yeah Romero has
quality and he is a very good Defender
but he's also a liability flag and you
know that we've seen it many times he is
a liability liabilities win World Cups I
don't think they do well when you have
lion Mery in the team you can be a
liability that's an alien speaking ofy a
man who said he's the best center back
in the world yeah but I appreciate and
respect you Turkish but I cannot have
your opinion over line Messi
know know
what that's that me saying so is the is
the best defender in the world I'm
Turkish I'm going to back my guys he's
good he's very good is good yeah yeah
he's good we're agree all right look
James you tried to give him the assist
for the Midfield I think it's time to
give an assist here because I don't
understand how flabs bought Romero to
the Gabriel table when listen it has
been close I think it was close to maybe
6 to8 months ago but this season again
Romero's proven to be a liability
standing this season in general in terms
of ability it's it's CRA America First
say I CRA do we agree on yes we do easy
y easy I foret one okay for
me I think it's both no chance I think
Gabrielle is Gabrielle has forgotten
about they are great pairing he scores a
lot of goals I think defensively he good
he has to deal with a lot wenko steps in
here I think he's very impressive and I
think because he's the bside you kind of
forget about him a little bit but Romero
scares me I think he's he is a liability
you know I was an a your wedding yes we
work to each other on a weekly basis
this is what you're doing to me on l b
for real this is what you're doing to me
do you know why you like me why I'm
authentic and so I'm sticking with how I
do not agree with this correct this
nonsense like I do not agree with this
at all so this whatever this is I'm not
signing off to you can put me in the
video that's why they got us to sign off
before the video
started is that what we sign I I agree
with this your face is by this 11 come
the thumbnail this is bull Romero is in
there how to G Gabrielle fullbacks
fullbacks full it gets worse no it
doesn't get worse it doesn't worse no no
no no Turkish let's let's which one
should we start let's go we'll go with
right back but Ben White isn't a right
back he defend is a center back he's
been made to play there it was a
argument between Ben White and tripier
last season the right back of the Season
easily that's a good point Tri is
probably number one that's fair that's I
don't mind that I Ben White is not is
not a better in terms of for Spurs
there's no world where R would want bent
white at Tottenham over Pedro perro
doesn't he's just not he's not Dynamic
enough doesn't move move in the same way
that porro does parro's vision his ging
his speed make him crucial to the kind
of football that Spurs play Ben White
doesn't get can overlap any he can
invert well he can run in a straight
line that's good he he he we could
based on what what we need and actually
por Arsenal would do
wonders there's there is no conversation
here I'm not even Ben bloody white ahead
of [__] I can't believe this this is
this is why this is why Ben White is
very disrespected in this country I
don't should be disrespect I don't
understand the I disrespect him how many
players have you seen take Ben right to
the cleaners that defensively he he has
been solid for 18 months and you forget
he's moved over from right back so he's
also someone that comes in like this and
the modern day philosophy comes in like
that but you know we can talk about that
when we move move on to left back but
the other thing is this is porro yeah
porro no no no porro is this as well
more so this is where he's been playing
and then W up if you like so is the one
of these yeah yeah something go like
that go kick in the goal yeah Ben White
he does his job he doesn't even like
football he does his job he goes home he
got selected for the World Cup something
happened behind the scenes and he said f
it let me go home cuz I'm happy at home
he doesn't really give too sh about
anything but coming 90 minutes
I don't want to play as long as you
perform you had one of those back in the
day asoto you never used to watch
football you used to love him I did love
him that's quite aich this won't make
the edit but that is that go check out
it makes the edit we love and he did ate
football he played for us as well that
definitely
work how how I know you're feeling bad
James because I am feeling bad this is
incorrect this is incorrect and that's
I think this is a much easier
conversation if if the England thing
kind of not happening that kind of makes
you think oh he's not as good as he is
like right back England are stacked I I
I can't not give it to him today today
today I can't this is the problem this
is the problem with these combined 11
isn't it because data set's not there
for so Spurs have a problem right the
Spurs have a problem the reason you're
here with me is you're supposed to give
me some stuff I've got to deal with the
comments as well I've got to deal with
the comment what about me the the facts
are he is
outrageously I respect I respect no
respect that hell of a lot cuz he is I'm
not talking about zinchenko here we must
we no we cannot got to finish the video
F A do is better than Z is some sort of
cast off from City you going to give
them four in the back are you genuinely
going to do this i' I'd like to I'd need
to world
AR I like a dogy but that's your weakest
argument of the Romero and poro and the
dog is quite quite convenient now we're
here yeah so so I categorically disagree
with this and this and I disagree with
whatever mentalness you're going to do
in a minute ad doi's 12 games in the
Premier League have been have been
really really good I agree uh his bull
carrying ability is amazing if he was
playing at Arsenal that' be like singing
from the rooftops about him the kids
ceiling is insane in Italy when he was
playing Udi statistic Bally the best
wing wing backers he was playing about
there in the uh in the
league didn't give a about zenko I
wouldn't want him near my team but now
we say well now I no so he's been there
he's he come from Manchester City and
then he's been playing for Arsenal in
this new system that the artet has had
is based on individual ability it's a
conversation definitely a conversation
of course like you've already said this
I know what's coming I never expected my
left back to end up here or here
I'm that's where plays no no 100% but
we're talking about zenko for in terms
of the amount of time he's coming here
done all of this and we've challenged
for a league title ad doi's come here
for 12 games and and it's been cute but
but you look at all theko
ISU even is ahead of the dogy in this
position slow down yeah I'm being real
no no he's not he's not slow down the
issue here right the issue here is that
these are players with that that are
that aren't bottle jobs right they
haven't bottled because they've had
nothing to bottle they are yet to bottle
they've had nothing to bottle the this
this team's in included bottled a fifth
place finish finish above Spurs to get
to the Champions League team last season
completely capitulated and bottled the
league actually what you've created in
this combined 11 he's at least seven or
eight B
jobs you're going to do it aren't you no
I'm not doing anything so just do it if
you're going to do it do it cuz I'm not
I'm done talking about a doy I think he
had a real chance there a doy I don't I
don't you I don't think you fought for
it propably after 12 games how am I
supposed to fight for someone with one
lead G find out way you go ceiling you
make it things that you can't actually
prove just yet you've let yourself down
there you let me you let me down pop it
down there youve let me down you've let
me down James no one agrees with this no
well let's know the comments com yeah
they'll be full of Arsenal we still got
one left yeah that's bararia no buy buy
your own one I got stats but by your own
words you said 12 games is not enough to
have an argument for a doggy behind
Allison is statistically the best shop
stopper in the league uh you don't even
have a number one you don't know who
your number one is R by the way was
signing for Tottenham and we looked at
him went this this all all this guy at
wants is out of brenford that's was on
record po K has said we looked at him
we've got no we've got a better option
in Vicario this is his word again I
respect your opinion T but you can't
have an opinion that's more valid than
Lion of Messi's when talking about the
best the best center back in the world
World Cup winner not gabri
right and this one which he says Vicario
was is a better option statistically a
better option has been fantastic this
season ramsdale is who ram
two who who's who's the number one
arteta hasn't said who's the number one
arteta's number one is Ry but listen I
put both ahead of Vicario that's the
problem 12 games this season doesn't
Trump Ram's performances for Arsenal
last season 12 games forio doesn't Trump
ri's performances forf do you remember
the issues the the the the the
predictions about Tottenham op and the
way they play football they're going to
concede so many goals high so high you
saw a game against Chelsea had nine men
down nine men we playing every High Line
High Line the reason why we haven't
conceded in the way that everyone
anticipated this because of this man I'm
look I'm going to give this one to flab
legitimately
leg I expected it relationship sa
because true a couple of reasons I think
got focus on this season to a point
because that is the difficult thing with
a lot of the topten ones second one is
like to to be in the position that he
has to play in your first 12 games in
the Premier League and to do what he's
done and play the way he's played that
is a lot of pressure and a lot of
decisions that you've got to get right
and he's done and also you know forget
that the other side of it when you're
you're playing out from the back
constantly dealing with a lot of
pressure from that side of it as well
for him to step in and do what he's done
I think it's been incredibly impressive
and I would say I think artetta has made
a mistake with the the way that he's
handled it I think he should have shown
a lot more clarity and it's led to both
those goalkeepers being a little bit n
nervy being they're being this whole
story around them and if you are playing
a final tomorrow I don't think it's a
question I think it's Vicario for the
for the record if we're judging it on
this season then Vicario I agree with
that okay so my my first 11 wouldn't be
this it would include Romero Pedro porro
and a doy right and you would have Ben
enor and Madison and you actually said
eight Tottenham players getting at the
beginning remember did I say eight and
look we've got eight Reds struggle
beautiful so there we have it but we
haven't got eight Reds right you and Jim
have got eight we put red here as well
forel yeah so do we do manages or
anything like n brilliant let like 12 a
body of work of 12 games good against
artet who's been there for 5 years for
600 million 800 million B yeah let's
compare them that's fair go on then come
on then get get out started get out
let's discuss this in a year's time
shall We There we go I'll happily come
back in a year's time so it'll be a lot
easier than this can we shake on it at
the
end no no no no no no no no hang on a
second I have to shake your hand because
it's extended right because I I would
you don't agree well I'm not shaking
hands on this no no no you said a year's
time and and all right all right year's
time if they love us yeah we'll see you
in a year's time go easy in the
[Music]
comments
right the next one I know it's a bit
close to your heart obviously you're a
good power a certain person on that
board and he works for him now as well
delious you going to do to your bus you
you L shouldn't have done this that's
naughty you shouldn't have done this
random
generator random generator ROM generator
a producer knew what he was doing and he
did their job perfectly